à
combi est une ville moderne et dynamique
en pleine expansion
mais tourner à droite ici suivez le
passage et vous voilà dans un autre
monde
bienvenue dans la forêt arrêt colonies
jungle urbaine de la taille de center
parcs
au milieu de cette oasis de végétation
animaux sauvages et humains cohabitent
8000 autochtone qu'on appelle les a dit
vas-y y habitent
répartis dans 27 villages sept
agriculteurs cultivent concombre et
aubergines les ai dit vers civile en
autarcie
même si certains vont régulièrement
faire un tour en ville perea mon coeur
bagdad a appuyé sa famille vite ici
depuis une génération
la tribu rejette la modernité et la
technologie asservissantes on a mis ce
chef a dit va s'y construit un
poulailler fabriquer tout en bout tous
les matériaux proviennent de la forêt
les békés kanak et il ya emporio les uns
diva si vénère le dieu de la verdure et
surtout les léopards ils considèrent les
félins comme les protecteurs de leurs
forêts
cette mère de famille se dépêchent de
faire des provisions d'eau
l'approvisionnement est un des
principaux problèmes est source de
conflits d adiva ci avec le monde urbain
la ville de leur fournit de l'eau qu'une
seule heure par jour
elle a besoin d'eau pour six personnes
pendant quatre jours les familles font
le plein selon un calendrier établi
entre elles la forêt a ri et non
seulement le poumon de la ville polluée
de bombay elle est aussi au coeur de la
mobilisation citoyenne en inde contre
l'empiètement urbain sur la nature et
les terres autochtones
une partie du territoire a été amputée
pour la construction d'une cité du
cinéma en 2010 la forêt était aussi
menacé par la construction du terminus
d'une ligne de métro
le projet a finalement été modifié et
les tracés passera ailleurs la moitié de
la forêt est en voie d'être désigné
zones écologiques protégées
mais ce chef a dit vassy continue
d'inciter à la vigilance contre les
promoteurs immobiliers qui convoite son
territoire si la ville continue de voler
ni terre dit il nous allons perdre notre
culture et notre identité
il a d'ailleurs composé cette chanson
implorant les léopards et les autres
dieux de la forêt de joindre la lutte
pour protéger la jungle urbaine
ici philippe blain radio-canada bombay
e